e aí
o seu sangue todos os reis
olá eu sou uma mulher que sangra todos
os meses e possivelmente durante toda a
minha vida sério que vai ser assim eu
tenho certeza que aí sentada nessa foto
aí a tem várias mulheres que também
sangram todos os meses vocês vão mente
do seu lado tem alguém que sangue todo
mês talvez seja alguém sangrando nesse
momento
é porque ninguém fala sobre isso é algo
tão natural
e é por isso que eu vou falar comigo
e se você não sangre você tá pensando ah
então esse assunto ele não é importante
para mim ele representa eu convido vocês
a refletirem sobre isso porque em
verdade você possivelmente se relaciona
intimamente com alguém sangra e você
nunca sequer se questionou que significa
e eu digo também que se não fosse pelo
sangue menstrual você não estaria aqui
hoje sobre o solo desta terra viva
porque o sangue esse mesmo sangue
menstrual é responsável pelo potencial
reprodutivo da espécie humana só
e quando eu menstruei pela primeira vez
ninguém falava muito sobre isso grande
sabor né e eu repetia com vergonha
vicente assustada com medo me sentir ali
com uma certa censura era algo que eu
achava particularmente estranho parece
que todo mundo lhe dava com isso com uma
certa naturalidade forçada as minhas
cenas de primeira menstruação era mais
ou menos assim eu levantando da carteira
no colégio e nem uniforme da escola todo
sujo de sangue ou eu andando na rua e um
cachorro enfiando por cima das minhas
partes íntimas ou naquele verão intenso
brasileiro ao suando com aquele plástico
e dando alergia ou eu tentando enfiar um
obreiro lugar que eu nunca tinha chegado
nada
é ou eu com as minhas amigas trocando
absorvente o pedindo emprestado e
passando como se a gente tivesse
traficando droga
o vídeo que que eram aquelas propagandas
de mulher com calça justa branca andando
a cavalo supostamente menstruada escrito
sempre livre
e aquele sangue azul meu sangue é
vermelho e quando eu olhava aquele
sangue azul eu realmente me sentia um
pouco estranho não pertencia a
e agora pergunto para você e quem aí na
plateia conhece alguém ou tem essa
experiência pessoalmente que não gosta
de menstruar quem aí na plateia conhece
alguém ou pessoalmente não gosta de
menstruar
e olha olha que não continuem com as
mãos bem levantadas e se olha
oi gente será que ela falando besteira
agora levanta a mão quem ama menstruar
ah não pera aí não faz tanto barulho que
a gente vai achar que muita gente
é só isso
ah tá
ei eu menstruo todos os meses atividade
festa se você também e é isso que a
gente tem como resposta
e depois de algum usando da minha
primeira menstruação eu tive um
desequilíbrio nos ovários e me fez
questionar a respeito de como ele dava
para o próprio corpo de mulher na época
já fazer algumas pesquisas sobre povos
originarios viajar o mundo em diferentes
posições do terceiro e nesse momento eu
decidi focalizar minha pessoa
o endereço de focalizar minha pesquisa
em mulheres da tradição e mantinha o de
alguma forma acesa a sabedoria desse
essa sabedoria ancestral dos sempre esse
ser mulher a primeira vez que eu entrei
em contato com isso que eu ouvi foi você
precisa reconectar com a sua menstruação
não sei não mas espera eu tô anos
criando técnicas muito requintada de não
ter que lidar com a minha menstruação e
agora você vai me dizer que eu preciso
reconectar com a minha menstruação e
eles eram sim isso foi meu primeiro
encontro de abuelas no peru na nos andes
agulhas andinas de mulheres a tradição
amandinha e claro sim você precisa
plantar a sua lua parecer ritualmente o
seu sangue para terra nua segundo elas é
diferente de menstruação por que a
menstruação faz uma menção algo linear
como algo do mês né e a lua é um ciclo
assim como a lua no ciclo menstrual e
e é vão para a lua seria então oferecer
o meu sangue para terra ritualmente
fazendo uma oferenda agradecendo a essa
grande mãe terra grande a kety pelo
feminino por todas as bençãos de ter um
corpo mulher eu falei e aí então não se
você fizer isso você vai limpar os seus
traumas as suas dores os seus medos toda
essa informação que existe nos seus
vários você o útero e talvez seja que
causam desequilíbrio falei ó não custa
nada tentar só que para eu tentar eu
teria que usar as presentes deixar de
usar fazer sustentáveis e usar as
presentes em qual loja
o parecer um pouco absoletos aos
caminhos da vovó mas eu fui descobrindo
com o tempo que na verdade eu estaria
deixando de jogar na terra 10 mil
absorventes mais ou menos o que uma
mulher durante a sua vida série
e eu deixaria já tá contribuindo para os
seus milhões absorvente que são jogados
na terra todos os dias e que demoram
mais ou menos 100 anos para fazer com pó
ligação interessei pelo menos eu não tô
conseguindo com ela senão a seguir e
além de tudo isso eu fui descobrir que
os absorventes descartáveis eles tinham
toxinas que podiam que estavam
diretamente em contato com mesmo rosa e
podiam me causar câncer e infertilidade
síndrome do choque tóxico causa morte
ninguém fala sobre isso
e ai eu acompanho com copinho paninho né
aquele paninho assim que você pega ela
foi mais tranquilo mas o que que
aconteceu eu tive que assumir que eu
tava menstruada porque se antes uma
presente de plástico eu pegava ele
enrolava jogava fora e passava pelas
minhas amigas vamos ver se está ficando
droga esse paninho eu tinha que colocar
no balde com água e você ficava o balde
cheio de sangue e eu tinha que lavar o
caminho que segurar o carinho no varal
então você passar o celular ao vivo meu
paninho e eu tinha que tirar você mandou
eu passear com ele onde é que eu fosse e
às vezes a gente guardar o coelhinho com
sangue na bolsa para chegar em casa ela
vai depois então eu tive que assumir
para as pessoas que eu tava menstruada
em verdade eu tive que assumir para mim
mesma eu sangrava isso é um processo bem
interessante um segundo momento com o
copinho sempre copinho coletor é o
seguinte você imagina você ensinar um
copinho no seu canal vaginal ele tá no
vácuo cheio de sangue menstrual e você
tem que tirar esse copo
o banho de menstruação
o desastre os primeiros dias foi um
desastre contente eu fui aprendendo e
com o tempo fui aprendendo também qual
que era o meu sangue saudável eu comecei
a ver qual é a cor do meu sangue qual
era a textura saudável do meu sangue
qual era o fluxo volume de fluxo do meu
sangue sim ou não com água e comecei a
observar inclusive e deixa seu estado
mental dependendo do meu stress do meu
cansaço esse sangue e esse fluxo água
eles também mudavam isso foi um processo
bem interessante também de apropriar da
minha saúde não precisa colocar na mão
de terceiro a minha menstruação a minha
saúde ao controle do meu corpo
eu sou eu uma planta da minha lua
achando lindo achando maravilhoso aí eu
comecei a hora com outras coisas muito
bizarras na minha vida depois isso assim
assado elas falavam né que quando você
fez isso aqui tá certo milagres
aconteciam que você procurava você com
criar uma coisa elas diziam que o sangue
era o instrumento de magia de poder só
que eu não vou falar detalhes sobre isso
porque eu ainda tô curando desde o
século 15 o meu trauma de ter sido
queimado na fogueira então a gente deixa
de ser uma conversa mais íntima depois
tá eu tava falando a minha lua só que
tinha uma coisa que ainda me incomodava
muito a respeito da menstruação e era o
fato de que eu me tornava improdutiva
quando tava sangrando
a cabeça eu tinha cólica eu falei
paciente eu não conseguia raciocinar
direito então enquanto tá todo mundo
daquele mundo louco capitalista
produzindo linearmente ai eu precisava
só da minha cama
eu não queria para você isso me
incomodava muito porque a gente tem um
mercado de trabalho muito competitivo
então na floresta de sequelas estados
unidos eu conheci uma boa ela também é
uma mulher dessa escala rosa que ela me
disse que na tradição dele as mulheres
elas enquanto estavam menstruadas
entravam dentro de uma tenda que ela
sendo a vermelha e ela se recolhiam
entre elas e elas não precisavam fazer
nada para a comunidade aquele no momento
que toda a comunidade entendia que elas
recebiam visões intuições a respeito do
que fazer no próximo ciclo de seus mais
importantes dentro da comunidade ela
falava também que nesse momento da
menstruação e do recolhimento é o
momento de maior potencial intuitivo da
mulher e quando ela recebe as visões que
ela precisa para o próximo 5
e era um momento as mulheres tampa seus
cabelos conversar vamos se cuidar você
amava pra cá vão saber eles falavam mal
do marido e era um momento que elas
tinham para elas mesmas como senso de
comunidade sabe e aí eu pensei gente
super legal eu chamei minhas amigas mas
não sei o trabalho de uma vez esse
semana feriados ou mais colo luta muito
na minha realidade só que eu fui
descobrindo com o tempo e pequenas
mudanças eu pudesse fazer na minha vida
na minha rotina e um grande benefício
por exemplo sair do trabalho eu tava um
dia exaustivo de trabalho para casa e me
recolher
é para ficar olhando a vida dos outros
lá no instagram e acender uma vela são
olhinho essencial no meu bem sempre
colocar uma bolsinha de água quente nas
respostas bandeirinha nos pé o vírus nos
próprios pensamentos e respiração e
cuidar
e foi uma grande diferença porque eu
entendi nesse momento que eu não
precisava ser uma super-heroína o tempo
todo uma super mulher eu tinha sim o
direito de descansar um
e isso me fez refletir também sobre o
que que nessa comunidade lakota
tradicional usa a comunidade apoia a
mulher nesse movimento de recolhimento
os homens inclusive imagina eu chegando
o meu trabalho falando é seu chefe aqui
comecei a sangrar hoje vou ficar 5 dias
ali tá na me atenda vou receber umas
inspirações para os projetos do próximo
ciclo daqui a pouco eu volto amor cuida
das crianças vira aí tá que eu vou aí
para você fazer ele com as minhas amigas
eu volto rezar por nós
e não é a nossa realidade realmente
desse na nossa realidade porque quando a
gente se recorda a gente não tá mais
servindo aos números do capitalismo
olá seguindo pouco mais com várias
dessas desconstruções através do sangue
menstrual
eu tinha uma coisa que ainda me
incomodava astros da mente e menstruar
eu não sei vocês mas eu sou uma pessoa
que é o forma de manhã e eu pergunto
tenta aí e cada dia uma nova morena que
estudou cada dia uma nova pessoa que
falei
e isso é muito confuso para mim diziam
que eram os hormônios tava demônio é um
caos por que imagina nas relações
íntimas era super difícil né algum dia
eu tava solteira amorosa super
acolhedora no outro dia eu tava ríspida
trava estou ainda né todo passado é
assim eu só sei como lidar né e aí cada
dia de um jeito cada dia de uma nova
forma se eu coloco o projeto para o
futuro aí depois eu mudava de ideia
porque agora o meu interesse é um depois
eu me interessei a outro e até que me
disseram ele só tende para de nicole de
uma parteira chamar outra lena ela falou
que as mulheres são cítricas e elas são
como a lua e ela me falou que se você
estudasse os diferentes padrões do seu
ciclo menstrual você começaria a
encontrar
se cuida do que estava se repetindo a
cada novo ciclo
o ou seja não era um caos não era uma
grande surpresa esses padrões ele se
repetindo de tempos em tempos dependendo
de onde eu estava no meu ciclo e aí eu
não conseguia não somente prever o que
ia acontecer mas também usar cada um
desses momentos com cada uma das suas
características como uma potencialidade
para agir de uma forma diferente no
mundo se é o momento de recolher eu
recolhi o seu momento de sair porque eu
tô com a mente mais linear com mais do
segmento é isso que eu faço eu sou mais
amorosa é isso eu dou amor e seguindo
esse fluxo de forma mais equilibrada ela
dizia que as mulheres são como a lua e
quando elas são menstruação como a lua
nova elas são como a semente ela só como
inverno elas uma semente latente embaixo
da terra nos seus labirintos
subterrâneos no escuro
um lugar que não se enxerga com os olhos
lugar visível ela dizia que a mulher
quando para de menstruar ela sobe como
uma flor que germina ela sobe começa a
primavera como esse sol que vai nascendo
e ela tem uma energia fresca e renovada
ela tá aberta para o mundo ela disse que
quando a mulher ovula ela tá no máximo
no whats e da cristã e ela disse quando
a mulher para a última fase do cinco ela
é como a lua minguante ela é como outono
ela começa a cercar suas peças ela
começa a secar e cair as suas folhas as
suas coisas que vão em direção ao chão
para proteger a raí
a receber o inverno mas quem é que serve
lingua
quem quer perder essas peças
e quer voltar para raio
é engraçado tem um pouco do movimento de
expansão e crescimento a isso deram o
nome de tpm
e eu aprendi como abuela uma mulher da
tradição do méxico e tpm tempo para
meditar
e ela me dizia assim não minha filha
você não você não deixa de ser quem você
é quando você tá na tpm você se torna em
verdade quem você é quando você tá na
tpm sem máscara e que benefício
maravilhoso é esse a gente pode ser real
com a gente mesmo ela disse para a gente
renascer a gente precisa saber morrer
e ela disse no início do ciclo e nessa
última fase é o momento que a gente olha
para aquilo que a gente viveu no nosso
último assim a gente pensa e se
questiona o que que eu não quero mais
para mim o que que eu deixo para farra
e esse é o momento que nos gera talvez
uma reatividade uma agressão porque não
está consciente e quando a gente usa
essas informações conscientemente para
trazer as transformações que a gente
quer para nossa vida e manifestar
realidade que a gente realmente deseja o
que realmente eu quero até termino traz
essa clareza ela traz a sombra à tona
em diante de tudo isso eu pergunto hoje
para você
se você pudesse dizer alguma coisa para
sua menina
é aquela que menstruou pela primeira vez
o que você diria
e a sua menina que você foi um dia ou a
sua menina sua filha ou sobrinha a sua
irmã a sua mãe que você diria para elas
no momento que ela se torna mulher se
ela recebe pela primeira vez esse sonho
e eu particularmente de algo bem
diferente eu disse para menina naquele
momento
e eu diria minha menina que sim eu quis
durante muito tem que ser homem ele fica
não menstruar mas se conhecendo esses
hábitos entende que o meu corpo mulher é
uma grande pro tempo
bom dia para ela que se tratando de ser
mulher pessoal é político sul
quem diria para ela que a gente vive
numa sociedade que sistematicamente nos
as pastas
o nosso potencial entre ichigo da nossa
força excessiva do nosso poder
visionário
e eu diria para ela que sim ter ou não
uma vagina definir os nossos privilégios
nosso lugares fala os nossos papéis
sociais
e eu diria minha menina que sim a gente
vive numa sociedade antropofa lu ego
logo cêntrica todos os palavras numa
palavra só misóginas e machistas e
objetifico os nossos corpos erotismo os
nossos corpos se preocupando os nossos
corpos que normatiza o corpo feminino
é mas eu diria a minha menina
e sobretudo
é amar o seu corpo mulher é
profundamente revolucionária obrigado
[Aplausos]